so I want to talk about something today
that's kind of a follow-up of a topic
that's been increasingly important in
the era of government in which we
currently find ourselves which is
activism and this sort of feeling of
helplessness that many of us
understandably have what can we actually
do to affect change and to get the
government and its really kind of a
partnership between government and
industry to listen to us to just listen
to people and a lot of our viewers and
listeners write in and there's a theme
to those emails which is signing
petitions doesn't really work voting is
important calling our elected officials
matters but what else can we actually do
to protest and to activate and to try to
get change to take place in a way that
would actually be good for the general
public and the population and there's a
number of interesting works papers books
on this topic that I've recently been
looking at and to remind you of where we
we kind of left this conversation before
the argument that we've been working
with or that I've been working with
anyway is that various forms of
nonviolent resistance I believe in the
long term are more effective than
violence we're more likely to win
agreement and be able to engage in
negotiation with governments and
Industry when we use nonviolent means of
resistance then violent now
understandably sometimes you are
activating in opposition to actions by
governments or industry that can be even
if not physically violent politically
violent or violent in the detrimental
impact that they have on people and so I
completely understand that in history
there have been times for violent
resistance but to kind of recap for our
conversation I believe that we are going
to be more effective activists if we do
the right type of nonviolent resistance
the two methods or tactics that I
previously have talked about a bunch of
times now are civil disobedience and
general strikes we've already talked
about those before the idea of using
general strikes and
civil disobedience to [ __ ] large
swathes of government and industry in a
way that would be very difficult to
ignore it doesn't guarantee and I
apologize as I punch my mic because I'm
starting to get wound up in anticipation
of the rest of the story it doesn't
guarantee that the activism will have
the results we necessarily want but they
are means that we'll be much more
effective in getting a response than
simply signing petitions online but I
have other ideas to talk to you about
today now full disclaimer most people
literally can't afford to do the stuff
I'm about to tell you most people are at
huge risk put themselves at huge risk to
your own finances to the finances of
your family to your own existence as
sort of a free person in society but the
idea is that with all of the tactics I'm
about to tell you to discuss with you if
everyone does it or a large number of
people do it you're less likely to be
targeted as an individual for doing it
and it will very quickly [ __ ] systems
that society depends on and it may it
may get the negotiating powers to the
table to really look at effecting change
so again most people aren't willing to
do this stuff right now I'm mostly also
not willing to do a lot of these things
because of the risk that's associated
with it but it's good to know that there
are more things you can do other than
right your elected officials and show up
at a rally and sign petitions online and
vote if the system works poorly enough
more and more people will be willing to
take it to the next level non-violently
and some examples include strategic
defaulting okay strategic defaulting is
when a borrower makes a decision to stop
making their payments mostly we're
talking about mortgages when we talk
about strategic defaulting economists
consider that a concerted strategic
defaulting efforts in the mortgage
industry would collapse the banking
industry unless there were massive
government bailouts and you would very
quickly get both the financial industry
which is responsible for many of the
problems we're dealing with and the
government to say we've got to do
something and it can't just be starting
to ding the credit reports of all these
people if
enough people do it okay that's the key
thing class-action lawsuits can be used
as activism if you have enough activist
lawyers willing to file them
class-action lawsuits against industry
for their destruction of public
resources maltreatment of public
individuals and customers class-action
lawsuits can be used and masked to
[ __ ] both companies and the court
system but you need a concerted effort
to actually do it mass rallies in urban
areas but to such a concerted degree
that the cities are effectively shut
down if this happens in one place sort
of authorities can kind of keep the
system moving if the largest twenty
cities in the United States are flooded
with people for mass rallies everything
from public transit to business gets
overwhelmed people can't go to work
don't have to be violent but we've got
to be there
rallying you will very quickly see that
the system cannot simply ignore that
stopping all non necessary financial
consumption this means no new iphone
unless yours literally doesn't work
anymore no eating out you buy the
minimum groceries necessary this will
have a massive impact on the economy
right away withholding scheduled
payments beyond mortgages we talked
about strategic defaults on mortgages
this could be withholding rent payments
utility payments general fiscal
non-compliance stop paying speeding
tickets and property taxes and again if
one person does it if a few people do it
they just get penalized for it if enough
people do it this stuff will [ __ ]
these systems that are in charge of the
financial system and that are dependent
on those payments coming in now what's
important to understand here Pat is that
in the short term a lot of these types
of activism can actually hurt people who
are doing the activism it can hurt
workers via layoffs it can hurt small
businesses but eventually if coordinated
in large quantities these are types of
protests that will fall
the government in industry to act will
it work
not necessarily but my point here is
it's good to know that you can do more
than just vote sign petitions and call
your elected officials not too long ago
I read Nelson Mandela's memoir a long
walk to freedom and he talked about the
four types of violent activism those
included everything from sabotage to
guerrilla warfare to terrorism and all
the way to outright revolution now I
would never advocate for those last
three and certainly apartheid South
Africa is far different than what we
have here in Trump's America today but
sabotage that's an interesting one
because that has to do with just tearing
down government property obstructing
roadways vandalism I guess you could say
it's violent but it's not violent
against particular people is that
something not certainly that you would
endorse but that you would put on the
table as something that could be
effective that could work well the thing
is that the tactics you listed some I
think would be over the line and are
clearly violent and some would sort of
be on this side of the line so I think
we'd have to sort of evaluate exactly
which tactic we are talking about
destruction of government property would
would be one thing
peaceful obstruction of roadways I think
is a different one but you're thinking
along the lines of how do we categorize
these different types of activism and my
message to you here is that there are
other tactics available if and when it's
time to use them is sort of a gray area
that we can kind of continue having a
conversation about